das rücke und herzlich willkommen wir
heute zu einem neuen blog auf einem
kanal meine lieben freunde es ist
ziemlich spät
aber ich wäre eine entschuldigung die
müllhalde ist eine andere richtung zu
fahren mit carola damit haben die hier
bei uns jetzt mal ein bisschen
umdisponiert und die beiden händen
julien hat einfach ein container hier
das da oben ist übrigens unsere wohnung
in den haag am sandra sala die steht
dass der fahrstuhl fährt einfach direkt
in unsere ruhe rein und das ist heißt es
nicht garnelen das hier ist auf jeden
fall das schlafzimmer von max und mir
hier ist hält dusche hier sind
badewannen jacuzzi und ausblick ins meer
und das andere
wir fahren jetzt ein bisschen alkohol
einkaufen bevor wir das machen hab ich
allerdings die frage an den handy plus
akku kann ich mit einer hand hochheben
aber so ein auto kann ich nicht mit
einer hand hochheben
woran liegt das
[Musik]
ich war eigentlich ein witz machen aber
die jacke wie hose die kamera auf den
boden geknallt
wir sind gerade einkaufen die ganze car
ist voll mit fünf minuten terrine und
chips was sagst du dazu
das problem ist wir sind hungrig
einkaufen gegangen wollten eigentlich
nur ein bisschen birk aufmerksam blickt
das alles was hier alles und alles was
noch da vorne ist also wir sind seit
bald 400 euro herbekommen jetzt weg aus
dem supermarkt acht wir können der
theoretisch ein taxi bestellen
unsere küche im erwin wie es bei der wm
eine richtig komisch also wie im hotel
einfach so richtig ja und wir haben zehn
ja richtig gut eingekauft sondern was
kriegt ja nicht von hier treffe
getroffen da die anderen ja gerade alle
draußen brauchen sind habe ich nur kurze
frage nicht weißt du was ich auf der
hans stephani ich habe frage ich weiß
was ich auf der hand stehen habe nein
richtig
[Musik]
wir gehen jetzt auf jeden fall feiern
freunde
gerade feiern und im club war es
eigentlich nicht so lustig ziemlich
beschissen aber dann sind wir mit einem
huber also mit seiner taxi alternative
nach hause gefahren und sandra dachte
die sprechen irgendwie deutsch jemand
kurz aus meiner aber geradeaus derart
schnell oder so ja die wird danach auch
noch fast rausgekickt du bist einfach
richtig angefangen meine sei dem motto
tochter youtube auf jeden fall jetzt
schlafen wir sehen uns morgen wieder mal
luca ein kleiner schnell interviewt er
wie geht's der scheiße interview ende
die cx leben heißt es ihr brötchen
gekauft hat und zu aber neun hammer
brauchte ich jetzt nicht
[Musik]
wir haben hier in den haag einfach einen
jungen gefunden mit der wir gerade
schnell kennen grundsätze sind wie wir
aufgebrochen von der polizei habe einen
wunderschönen golden retriever ist weg
jetzt das ist so einen hund den ich auf
jeden fall mit kaufen möchte nicht in
hamburg bin ist das für ein kunstwerk
mal besondere aber stets da hinten
kommen wieder zurück zu uns jetzt hier
sieht einfach aus wie russland hier aber
mit einer holland lagerung was keiner
von uns hat sich etwas zu essen bestellt
aber sandra hatte ich zweimal rot mit
aioli bestellt was ist dein kommentar
dazu hier in los angeles oder was
das sind einfach so richtiges andere
schuhe wir sind für einen kleinen
supermarkt und die haben einfach
traumfänger geht es los
die hat man sich einfach ins bett
gegangen da mag aufsichtrat diese
sondern posieren neben deiner familie
hier kurz salat kondome gekauft und ich
habe mir eine the bomb gesichtswasser
gekauft da sieht man wollte oder
instagram pushen in meinem blog heißt
auch instagram laserlicht wir also laser
luca ok laser lokale folgen
da kannst du auch so ein typisches
falschen das foto von mir
ich hasse das wenn wir da nicht wissen
muss wir sind wieder zu hause angekommen
und spielen gerade ein trinkspiel mit
einem tick tock filter ich glaube der
tik tok bild aber nicht dafür gedacht
aber das ist ein face tracking filter
und der film immer nur die person die
gerade carola was tust du
jetzt musst du einen schluck trinken
beispielsweise und dadurch dass die
trinker kennt der teck topfit jetzt
nicht mehr das gewicht und jetzt seine
du musst das klappt nicht
wir haben jetzt hier zu ende vor
getrunken freunde gehört auch schon an
meiner etwas veränderten stimme und
sprechgeschwindigkeit wir fahren jetzt
in den club wert hebt das recht auf der
toilette angelassen
danke für die antwort auf jeden fall von
wird in den club in die stadt und ich
nehme eine alkohol moment mit der haben
wir unter anderem schon eine fussball
challenge gemacht und wir sind damit auf
fahrrad gefahren in amsterdam und viele
leute von euch meinten unter den videos
dass wir doch mal mit der alkohol brille
betrunken
die aussetzen sollten und das machen wir
jetzt gleich nachdem wir aus dem klub
wieder raus
also sagen hat auf jeden fall in dem
club war auch ganz gut aber
mir
wir testen jetzt das was im titel steht
und zwar dass wir betrunken mit der al
kubra herumlaufen
ok kurzes update das war für euch dass
gerade ein paar sekunden aber für uns
lassen gerade eine stunde und fragen mir
die brille gesucht wird irgend jemand im
club verloren sie wiedergefunden die la
kings am tisch davon schild die polizei
und wir sind auf dem beleuchteten platz
aber max ist jetzt der erste der die
brille auf bekommen und einfach ein
bisschen kommen muss also die sind alle
weg ich ein bisschen betrunken ich
glaube dass sie bei mir
[Musik]
carola sich dass mit tabu ist das geil
sind davon nicht schilder war die
polizei und passt auch dass sich die
fläche komischen gestalten
kicker was ist mit dir ich weiß gar
nicht wo sie hingeht
die ja große zurück ich verstehe nicht
was dieser liege sagt luca nur dreckig
[Musik]
die mal im kreis das schlimmste ist
wirklich immer so ganz schnell auf leute
zu läufern man halt denken die leute
sind extrem weit weg aber die leute sind
komplett nach venedig wurde das war auf
jeden fall der flug für heute meine
damen und herren ich habe jetzt die
letzten beiden tage hier in den haag
eine ahnung ins spiel
wenn man ist dass die ungarn kataster es
okay wäre perfekt ja guten appetit auf
jeden fall war das jetzt den block vor
den letzten beiden tagen und mittwoch
kommt die glock vor den nächsten beiden
tagen die wir jetzt hier haben
von daher wünschen lassen like da und
haben einen kanal der das letzte wort
hasse dich
[Musik]